- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame
la Première ministre,
mesdames et messieurs
les membres du gouvernement,
mes chers collègues,
la France
est en deuil.
Trois ans
après Samuel Paty,
un autre professeur,
un homme de culture
et de dialogue
qui avait la passion
de transmettre
la connaissance,
Dominique Bernard,
est tombé
sous les coups
d'un terroriste
qu'il tentait courageusement
de raisonner.
Plus encore qu'un crime,
c'est une profanation
qui s'est commise à Arras.
En France, l'école est sacrée.
Elle est le sanctuaire
du savoir
où se forme la nation.
S'attaquer à l'école,
à travers un professeur,
revient à défier
notre république
tout entière.
Notre modèle
humaniste de société
que nous défendrons toujours.
Hier, dans toutes les écoles
de France,
les élèves
et leurs enseignants
ont observé une minute de silence.
Je ne doute pas que chacun
d'entre
vous se soit associé
à ce moment
de recueillement,
de civisme et d'unité.
Il me paraît important
et indispensable
que la représentation
nationale,
à son tour, rende hommage
à Dominique Bernard
et Samuel Paty.
Je souhaite également
que nous exprimions
notre solidarité
à nos amis belges
et suédois,
durement frappés hier
à leur tour
par le terrorisme islamiste.
Pour nos deux professeurs,
pour toutes les victimes
du terrorisme,
en Europe et ailleurs,
je vous demande,
mesdames et messieurs
les membres
du gouvernement,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
de bien vouloir
observer une minute
de silence.
Je vous remercie.
Madame la Première
ministre,
vous avez la parole.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés,
depuis vendredi
dernier, la France
est en deuil.
Au lycée Gambetta d'Arras,
le terrorisme islamiste
a frappé.
Il a emporté la vie
d'un professeur
de lettres,
Dominique Bernard,
sauvagement assassiné
en s'interposant face
à l'agresseur
pour protéger les élèves
et l'école.
Par ce geste,
il a été rempart
de la République.
Avec vous, au nom
du gouvernement,
je veux lui rendre
hommage, dire
ma solidarité
à sa famille
et à ses proches.
Vendredi dernier,
lors de cette même attaque,
un autre enseignant
et deux agents
ont été blessés.
Nous sommes à leurs côtés
et nous sommes aux côtés
des équipes, des élèves
et des parents
du lycée Gambetta.
Je veux aussi profiter
de cet instant
pour dire
ma solidarité et celle
de la France
avec la Belgique
et la Suède,
après l'attentat
qui a deux morts
hier, à Bruxelles.
Mesdames et messieurs,
à tous les enseignants
de France, à tous
ceux qui sont attachés
à nos valeurs
républicaines, je le dis,
nous ne renoncerons pas.
Nous ne renoncerons pas à faire
vivre
la transmission des savoirs,
le débat d'idées,
la liberté de penser.
Nous ne renoncerons pas
à former
notre jeunesse,
à lui montrer le cap
de la République
et de la citoyenneté.
Nous ne renoncerons pas
à porter
nos valeurs et défendre
la cohésion nationale.
La France
est debout,
la République est debout.
Si nous sommes unis,
personne ne peut
nous faire ployer.
Je vous remercie.
Applaudissements nourris
...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
madame la Première ministre.
L'ordre du jour
appelle les questions
au gouvernement.
La première question
va être posée
par madame la présidente Panot.
- Mathilde Panot:
Trois ans après l'acte terroriste
islamiste qui a ôté
la vie à Samuel Paty,
professeur d'histoire,
une fois de plus,
un enseignant est assassiné.
Une fois de plus,
l'obscurantisme s'attaque
au lieu de la diffusion
des lumières
du savoir.
Une fois de plus,
le sens d'une religion
est dévoyé au contraire
de ses valeurs.
Une fois de plus,
le pays aura pu constater
l'engagement total
de ses enseignants
pour ses enfants.
Dominique Bernard
a été assassiné
et ses collègues blessés
parce qu'ils ont affronté
eux-mêmes la mort
plutôt que de laisser
les élèves en danger.
Aurélie, sa collègue,
décrit son rapport
aux jeunes.
"Tu étais là
pour eux,
ils avaient compris ça
et ils se nourrissaient
de ta passion
pour la littérature
et des espoirs
que tu mettais en eux."
Notre pensée émue
va à l'ensemble
de celles et ceux qui,
partageant
la même profession,
sont d'autant
plus accablés depuis vendredi.
Nous leur disons
votre douleur
et la nôtre.
Face à la barbarie
du meurtre,
il est rude de continuer
à garder foi
en l'humain.
En voyant le courage
de ces enseignants,
nous savons que,
pour vaincre la terreur,
il faut éclairer
les chemins
par les lumières de la raison.
La transmission
est le coeur d'une société
qui assume son devoir
devant l'avenir.
Une société qui veut
continuer à vivre
en commun sous une même
loi, assurant
la liberté de chacun
dans le respect
de l'autre, c'est-à-dire,
à faire république.
L'école est le lieu
où se construit
cette oeuvre
qui libère l'esprit
de la nuit des préjugés.
L'école a été visée.
Vous devez prendre
toutes les mesures
pour protéger
les personnels
et les élèves.
Mais surtout,
l'école doit continuer
à oeuvrer
à l'émancipation
de tous les citoyens.
Elle doit être dotée de tous
les moyens nécessaires
pour cela.
Allez-vous, comme le demandent
les enseignants,
recruter tous
les personnels essentiels
à l'encadrement des élèves?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la présidente
Panot,
c'est avec gravité
que je veux
vous répondre aujourd'hui.
Vous avez rendu hommage
à Dominique Bernard.
Cet hommage, nous le devons
à ce professeur
de lettres tombé,
comme Samuel
Paty avant lui, sous les coups
du terrorisme islamiste.
J'ai eu l'occasion
de m'exprimer,
et j'aurai l'occasion
d'en dire davantage
dans les minutes qui viennent.
Madame la présidente Panot,
je veux rendre hommage également
aux victimes
de l'attaque terroriste
qui a frappé Bruxelles hier.
Je veux rendre hommage,
enfin, aux victimes
des attentats barbares
qui ont frappé Israël.
Des attentats
terroristes commis
par un groupe
terroriste, le Hamas.
Applaudissements nourris
...
Un groupe que vous refusez
de qualifier
comme tel, un groupe
que certains,
parmi vous, ont même
osé qualifier
de "mouvement de résistance".
Depuis le 7
octobre, les voix
de La France
Insoumise manquent
à la condamnation unanime
de la barbarie terroriste.
Elles manquent
à l'unité nationale.
Vous avez tenté de justifier
vos ambiguïtés,
mais ce matin,
la réalité est apparue
au grand jour.
La justice est saisie,
elle tranchera.
En entendant
ces propos, je pense
à ces jeunes tués lors d'une fête.
Je pense à ces massacres
dans des régions israéliennes,
je pense à ces femmes,
ces hommes,
ces personnes âgées
et ces enfants enlevés.
Pour vous,
ce ne sont pas des actes
terroristes.
Je vous remercie.
Applaudissements nourris
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
Merci, madame
la Première ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Falorni.
- Olivier Falorni:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Dominique Bernard
était professeur
de lettres.
Il aimait les livres
et il aimait
les mots.
A ses élèves,
il aimait leur apprendre
les mots comme on offre
un présent
pour leur construire un avenir.
A ses élèves,
il aimait leur apprendre
les mots,
car il savait
que ce sont des joyaux
de connaissance
et de tolérance.
Vendredi dernier,
Dominique Bernard
est mort d'enseigner,
assassiné
par la barbarie
du terrorisme islamiste.
Face à ces tragédies
et à leur répétition,
les mots peuvent désormais
nous sembler usés
et inutiles.
Pourtant, je me refuse
d'y renoncer.
Je veux donc dire,
ici et avec vous,
aux familles
des victimes,
à tous les enseignants
de France
et à tous les agents
de l'Education nationale,
tout notre soutien
et toute notre affection.
Applaudissements
"On ne prostitue pas
impunément
les mots", comme disait
Albert Camus.
Cette phrase résonne
comme un avertissement
à tous ceux qui hurlent
à l'offense
quand vous parlez
de liberté d'expression,
à tous ceux qui hurlent
à l'islamophobie
quand vous défendez
simplement la laïcité.
Elle résonne
comme un avertissement
à ceux qui trahissent
les mots par fanatisme
ou par cynisme,
à ceux
pour qui il est visiblement
plus facile
de dire "police fasciste"
que de dire "Hamas terroriste".
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Mon cher collègue?
- Olivier Falorni:
Trois ans après l'assassinat
de son frère,
le frère de Samuel Paty
a trouvé les mots justes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Gabriel Attal.
Il faut couper le chrono.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député
Olivier Falorni,
vendredi,
le terrorisme islamiste
s'en est pris à nouveau
à notre école.
Vendredi,
le terrorisme islamiste
a assassiné Dominique Bernard.
Vendredi, ils ont frappé.
Notre école reste debout.
Elle reste debout à Arras,
où je veux saluer l'immense
courage, l'absolue dignité
et l'admirable ténacité
de la communauté enseignante.
Comme partout en France,
notre communauté éducative
fait face, elle fait bloc.
A nous de lui dire
aujourd'hui
toute notre
reconnaissance
et toute notre admiration.
La nation tout entière
est meurtrie
par l'assassinat
de Dominique Bernard.
C'est la barbarie
abjecte du terrorisme
qui frappe à nouveau.
Ils ont voulu
attaquer notre école
à la française.
Notre école
est un obstacle ultime
à leur funeste projet.
Les islamistes
veulent tenir éloigné
du savoir
le plus grand nombre
pour imposer leur obscurantisme.
Notre école
à la française défend
la démocratisation
du savoir pour tous!
Les islamistes
veulent soumettre
les femmes.
Notre école accueille
toutes les petites filles
de Français et tous
les petits garçons
pour leur transmettre le savoir!
Les islamistes veulent
imposer le règne
de la religion à l'école.
Nous imposons
celui
de la République
et de la laïcité
dans toutes les écoles de France!
Oui, nous continuerons
à défendre
ces valeurs
qui ne sont pas des concepts
abstraits.
Ils sont des combats
de tous les jours
qui doivent être défendus
par chacune
et chacun d'entre
nous comme vous,
monsieur le député.
Je veux dénoncer
celles
et ceux qui manquent
dans ce combat,
et je veux aussi
relever que,
dans les jours
et les semaines qui viennent,
les Français continueront
à faire face
à faire bloc
derrière leurs enseignants.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Fabien Roussel.
- Fabien Roussel:
Madame la présidente,
madame la Première ministre,
Dominique Bernard,
professeur de français,
a été assassiné
par un terroriste
islamiste
dans son lycée.
Trois autres collègues
ont été blessés.
Trois ans
après l'assassinat barbare
de Samuel Paty,
encore une fois,
la République
est attaquée, meurtrie.
Encore une fois,
l'école de la République,
les personnes
qui la font vivre,
sont prises pour cible.
C'est toute la nation
qui est endeuillée.
Au nom des députés
communistes,
nous nous inclinons
pour honorer
leur mémoire,
leur bravoure
et pour rendre hommage,
le coeur serré,
à toute une profession
qui exerce
le plus beau métier du monde.
Lors de la minute
de silence, j'ai mesuré
les peurs, recueilli
la souffrance
des parents, des enfants,
des enseignants.
Il faut les rassurer.
Si l'école publique
est ciblée,
c'est parce qu'elle est le
meilleur rempart
contre l'obscurantisme.
C'est parce qu'elle développe
l'esprit critique face
au dogmatisme.
Ce nouveau crime nous oblige,
une nouvelle fois,
à nous unir et,
d'une seule voix,
à condamner le terrorisme
et la barbarie
qui frappent nos écoles.
Rien ne peut
les justifier, ni ici,
ni ailleurs.
Cela nous oblige aussi
à avoir une réponse
à la hauteur
de cette attaque,
à dire haut
et fort
que nous ne combattrons pas
la haine
par la haine
mais par le droit
et la justice,
à dire ensemble
que nous ne céderons pas
à la peur,
pas plus qu'à la division
de nos concitoyens
selon leur religion
ou leurs origines.
Au contraire,
la plus belle
et la plus forte
des réponses,
c'est de donner
tous les moyens
à nos enseignants,
à notre école publique,
pour qu'elle puisse
remplir totalement
sa mission émancipatrice,
son enseignement universaliste
et humaniste.
Madame la Première ministre,
les enseignants attendent
tellement de l'Etat.
Quels moyens
entendez-vous mettre
au service de l'école
de la République?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député
Fabien Roussel,
nos 12 millions
d'élèves en France
ont une chance inouïe:
pouvoir compter
sur 860.000 enseignants
à leurs côtés, 860.000 enseignants
et toute la communauté
éducative
autour d'eux,
qui ont comme vocation
de démocratiser
le savoir et permettre
à chacun de briser
les destins écrits
par avance.
C'est leur vocation.
Ils la poussent
chaque jour à son maximum.
A Arras, leur réaction
a été exemplaire
pour mettre à l'abri leurs élèves.
Ils ne devraient pas
être confrontés
à cette situation.
La vocation d'un enseignant
est de sauver
des vies par la pédagogie.
Notre responsabilité
est de leur apporter
tous les moyens
pour qu'ils soient
en sécurité.
En sécurité physique,
dans des bâtiments sécurisés,
on doit toujours
être plus en sécurité
dans une école.
En sécurité intellectuelle,
car à l'heure
où un enseignant sur deux déclare
s'être auto-censuré
dans ses enseignements,
par crainte
de représailles,
notamment sur les questions
de laïcité.
La peur d'enseigner,
c'est un poison mortel
pour notre école.
C'est ce que veulent
les terroristes.
Ils veulent détruire
notre école
car elle ne correspond pas
à leurs projets.
Ils veulent faire peur.
Notre responsabilité
est d'être absolument
au rendez-vous de cette sécurité.
J'ai passé toute la soirée
de vendredi
et toute la matinée
d'aujourd'hui
avec les organisations
syndicales
des enseignants.
Je serai demain
avec les représentants
des collectivités
locales, notamment
sur la question
de la sécurisation
des bâtiments.
Beaucoup a été fait,
ces dernières années.
Beaucoup reste
à faire, en lien
avec elles et avec eux.
Nous devons
continuer à avancer
sur la question
de la transmission
et la lutte contre l'auto-censure.
Il nous faudra une unité
des forces politiques.
C'est tout simplement
le projet
de la République.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Jacqueline Maquet.
- Jacqueline Maquet:
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la Première ministre.
La République a été
frappée au coeur,
à Arras.
Dans cet hémicycle,
nous incarnons
la nation.
Je tiens à rendre
un hommage solennel
à Dominique Bernard qui,
par son sacrifice,
a sauvé de nombreuses vies.
Un homme rare,
un homme exceptionnel.
Je pense à ses collègues
gravement blessés.
Je pense au proviseur,
qui a fait preuve d'une bravoure
hors norme.
Je salue l'ensemble
des personnels
du lycée Gambetta
qui ont protégé
les élèves.
J'exprime ma gratitude
aux services
de secours.
Les policiers
étaient sur les lieux
en moins de quatre minutes.
Ils continuent d'accompagner
psychologiquement
les élèves de la communauté
éducative.
Merci à eux.
Trois ans après Samuel Paty,
le terrorisme islamiste tente
à nouveau de nous diviser
en s'attaquant
à notre école.
Face à cela,
notre réponse doit
être ferme, unie, déterminée.
Au-delà de nos émotions
profondes,
de notre colère
légitime
et de notre aspiration
à la justice,
il est de notre responsabilité
de poser
les questions essentielles
pour l'avenir
de notre pays.
Madame la Première ministre,
quels engagements prenez-vous
pour protéger
notre jeunesse
et nos enseignants face
à l'obscurantisme?
Comment mieux armer
notre public face
à cet ennemi insidieux?
Notre devoir est d'agir
avec détermination
et clairvoyance.
Nous devons à nos concitoyens
des actes forts
et concrets pour garantir
la pérennité
de notre modèle républicain.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée
Jacqueline Maquet,
vendredi dernier,
au lycée Gambetta d'Arras,
dans votre circonscription,
le terrorisme islamiste
a frappé, emportant la vie
de Dominique Bernard,
blessant un autre
enseignant
et deux agents.
Mes premières pensées
vont aux victimes.
Comme le président
de la République,
dès vendredi,
à Arras, je tenais
à leur dire ma solidarité,
mon soutien
et celui de mon gouvernement.
Nous sommes avec eux.
Je mesure les inquiétudes
des enseignants,
des élèves et des parents,
ces derniers jours.
Les inquiétudes
des Français, choqués
par cette attaque
sauvage, préoccupés
par la situation
internationale
et par l'attaque terroriste
hier à Bruxelles.
Madame la députée,
face aux inquiétudes,
vous demandez
des actes forts
et des actes fermes.
Comme l'a dit le président
de la République,
nous serons impitoyables.
Nous avons pris
des mesures immédiates
pour renforcer
la sécurité du territoire
et de nos écoles.
Vendredi soir,
le plan Vigipirate
a été rehaussé
au plus haut niveau.
10.000 policiers
et gendarmes sont mobilisés.
Le président de la République
a décidé d'engager 7000 militaires
dans l'opération Sentinelle.
La sécurité
aux abords des écoles
a été renforcée
avec, notamment,
le déploiement
de personnels de prévention
et de sécurité
de l'Education nationale.
Cela s'ajoute
à des investissements
de long terme aux côtés
des collectivités
pour la sécurité des écoles.
Nous poursuivons
notre lutte intraitable
contre le terrorisme.
Les services de renseignement
sont mobilisés.
Leur action
est déterminante et je veux
les saluer.
Nous accélérons pour expulser
les étrangers radicalisés.
Dès vendredi,
à la suite d'une réunion
de sécurité
autour du président
de la République,
le ministre de l'Intérieur
a demandé aux préfets
d'examiner
au cas par cas
l'expulsion immédiate
des étrangers radicalisés.
Madame la députée,
trois ans jour
pour jour
après l'assassinat sauvage
de Samuel Paty,
c'est à nouveau
une école qui est prise
pour cible.
L'école, c'est la transmission
des savoirs,
c'est l'apprentissage
de la liberté,
c'est le creuset
de la citoyenneté
et de la laïcité,
c'est l'émancipation,
c'est notre jeunesse
qui se forme,
qui grandit, qui choisit sa vie.
S'en prendre
aux enseignants,
c'est s'en prendre
à notre modèle républicain.
Nous serons là
pour protéger les Français.
Nous serons là pour protéger
la République.
Nous resterons
unis, rassemblés
autour de nos valeurs.
L'obscurantisme et la terreur
ne l'emporteront jamais.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, madame
la Première ministre.
- Jacqueline Maquet:
Merci, madame
la Première ministre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
S'il vous plaît.
La parole est à monsieur
le président Olivier Marleix
pour le groupe Les Républicains.
- Olivier Marleix:
Une fois de plus,
une fois de trop,
le terrorisme islamiste
a frappé notre pays.
Une fois de plus,
trois ans
après la mort
de Samuel Paty,
nous voilà réduits
à pleurer la disparition
d'un enseignant,
admirable de courage,
Dominique
Bernard,
que la République
aurait dû protéger.
En 10 ans, la France
a pleuré 273 victimes
du terrorisme islamique.
Quand est-ce que la France
sortira
du déni de réalité
et prendra la mesure
de la gravité de la crise?
Ne sommes-nous là
que pour nous lever
et compter les minutes de silence?
Nous sommes ici
pour donner à la France
les moyens d'agir
face à la barbarie.
C'est un combat digne
de notre histoire
et de nos valeurs.
Non, monsieur
Gérald Darmanin,
votre texte n'aurait rien empêché.
Il aurait juste permis
que le terroriste d'Arras
soit le 120.000e destinataire
d'une obligation
de quitter
le territoire français
non exécutée.
Quand allez-vous
admettre
que vous n'avez pas
le contrôle
de notre politique migratoire?
Ce n'est plus la loi qui décide.
Ce n'est pas le ministre
qui décide.
Tous ceux qui sont passés
par le ministère
de l'Intérieur le savent:
en matière d'expulsion
des étrangers,
c'est le juge
qui a le dernier mot.
C'est lui qui décide
le nombre d'obligations.
C'est lui qui crée
des obligations nouvelles,
ce qui s'impose
à la représentation nationale
et bafoue la volonté
du peuple souverain.
Face à cette impuissance
organisée,
la seule réponse est de changer
la Constitution.
Changeons la Constitution
pour permettre
à la France de retrouver
sa souveraineté,
redonnant la parole
au peuple français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
S'il vous plaît.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Face au terrorisme islamiste
qui a frappé
notre pays vendredi,
nous avons le devoir
d'être à la hauteur.
Etre à la hauteur,
c'est ne rien céder
à la haine, faire
bloc et faire vivre
notre cohésion nationale
et notre unité.
Etre à la hauteur,
c'est aussi lutter fermement
contre le terrorisme.
La menace est forte.
L'attentat d'hier
à Bruxelles
nous le rappelle.
Nous avons pris
des mesures immédiates
pour assurer la sécurité
des Français, notamment
en rehaussant
la posture Vigipirate
au niveau urgence attentat.
Nous serons impitoyables
avec une attention particulière
pour les étrangers radicalisés.
900 ont été expulsés depuis 2017.
Nous avons intensifié
l'examen
de la situation
des étrangers connus
pour islamisme radical.
Il n'y a pas de place
en France
pour ceux qui attaquent
la République.
Nous sommes d'accord
sur quelque chose:
nous devons faire
évoluer notre droit
et nos pratiques,
quand cela est nécessaire.
Nous devons le faire rapidement.
Comme vous, je crois
que notre système d'asile
a besoin
d'être réformé
et que nous devons
mieux maîtriser
nos flux migratoires.
Nous devons mieux lutter
contre l'immigration illégale
et expulser plus facilement
les individus
en situation irrégulière.
Nous devons retirer
les titres des personnes
qui menacent notre pays.
Ce sont certains
des objectifs portés
par le ministre
de l'Intérieur sur lesquels
nous voulons continuer
à travailler
avec vous et avec
toutes les personnes
qui veulent répondre
aux défis migratoires.
Un projet de loi
que nous sommes prêts
à faire évoluer
en prenant
toutes les mesures
utiles et efficaces.
Efficacité, fermeté
et cohésion nationale,
voilà le sens
de la politique
que nous portons,
et voilà comment
nous apporterons
des réponses aux défis
devant nous,
sans jamais rien céder
sur nos valeurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Francesca Pasquini.
- Francesca Pasquini:
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de l'Education nationale.
En toute sincérité,
je ne sais pas
si c'est la maman,
l'enseignante
ou la députée qui s'exprime.
Lorsque j'ai appris le décès
du professeur Dominique Bernard,
lorsque j'ai appris qu'un nouvel
attentat terroriste
avait frappé l'école,
j'ai eu peur,
en tant que maman.
Je me suis sentie
impuissante
en tant qu'élue.
Je me suis sentie meurtrie
en tant qu'ancienne enseignante.
Par mécanisme de défense,
mon cerveau
a refusé les images
terribles des médias.
Dans ma tête,
tournaient en boucle
les images du compagnon
d'une victime dansant
lors de ses funérailles.
En offrant une dernière
danse à la personne
qu'il chérissait,
il avait mis en scène
la parfaite allégorie
de l'enseignement.
Il avait donné
le tempo, la mesure
et la dynamique.
Ils avaient porté
collectivement
un message d'espoir,
d'amour et de résilience.
Le travail quotidien
de la communauté éducative,
c'est celui-là.
Grâce à eux, le lieu
d'émancipation qu'est l'école sera
toujours synonyme de liberté.
Les enseignants mènent
un noble combat
au quotidien.
Nous devons
faire en sorte
que leurs valeurs
fleurissent au sein
de l'école.
Cela n'est possible
que si nous en faisons
notre priorité
et allons tous
dans la même direction.
Comment comptez-vous
accompagner, épauler
et rassurer la communauté
éducative endeuillée?
Depuis trois ans,
les enseignants meurent.
Combien de temps
faudra-t-il
pour en tirer une leçon?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Madame la députée
Francesca Pasquini,
je le disais à l'instant,
en réponse
à Fabien Roussel,
la responsabilité
qui est la nôtre,
c'est d'être à la hauteur
des attentes
des enseignants
et de leurs besoins
pour leur permettre d'exercer
la mission
qui est la leur,
celle de transmettre
à nos enfants,
dans des conditions
de sécurité optimales.
Dès samedi soir,
j'ai tenu à réunir
les députés des Affaires
culturelles,
de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat
pour faire un point
sur ce sujet-là.
A la suite de chaque attaque
terroriste
dans notre pays,
les gouvernements
qui se sont succédé,
y compris
avant 2017,
ont pris des mesures
pour renforcer la sécurité
de nos établissements.
Cela a probablement
permis d'éviter
un carnage absolu à Arras,
surtout l'équipement
de cet établissement,
d'un plan de mise
en sûreté et,
je le dis devant vous,
la réaction des équipes
de direction
et des enseignants
qui a été exemplaire
pour mettre tous
les élèves à l'abri.
Ils disposaient
de ces équipements
et de ces formations.
L'enjeu est de garantir
que, partout
en France, dans tous
nos établissements scolaires
et nos écoles, les équipes
puissent travailler
en sérénité,
en sachant
qu'elles sont protégées.
C'est l'enjeu de la réunion
que j'aurai demain
avec les associations
d'élus pour faire
un point avec eux.
Un audit avait été
réalisé en 2015
sur les établissements scolaires.
Il s'agit de comprendre
quels efforts
ont été réalisés.
100 millions d'euros
ont été investis
depuis 2017
sur la sécurisation
des écoles
et des bâtiments publics.
Ils manquent de dispositifs
de sécurisation.
L'enjeu est d'avancer
rapidement
avec les collectivités
territoriales
pour être au rendez-vous
de l'attente absolue
et de notre responsabilité
absolue,
qui est celle de protéger
la communauté éducative
qui a besoin de protection
et de sécurité
pour faire son travail.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
- Francesca Pasquini:
Merci
pour votre réponse.
Ce qui a évité
un carnage à Arras,
c'est aussi qu'un
enseignant s'est interposé
entre les élèves et un terroriste.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
la présidente Isabelle Rauch.
- Isabelle Rauch:
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre
de l'Education nationale.
Nos professeurs sont là
pour nous faire grandir,
pas pour risquer leur vie.
S'attaquer
aux écoles,
ce n'est pas normal, c'est nul.
Nous vivons dans un pays en paix.
Nous ne pouvons pas
tolérer ça,
encore moins de la part
d'un élève
du lycée.
Ce sont les mots
de jeunes lycéens
qui ont organisé hier,
dans la circonscription,
avec l'aide
de leurs professeurs,
une cérémonie
de recueillement
à la mémoire
de Dominique Bernard
et Samuel Paty.
leurs dilemmes
et leur silence,
comme des fêlures face
à la marge d'amende.
Ils ont hommage
à Dominique Bernard,
à Samuel Paty,
avec la conscience qu'avec
leur assassinat,
c'est la communauté nationale
qui est visée.
C'est toute la République
qui est attaquée.
Elle porte l'émancipation
par le savoir, l'affranchissement
des dogmes, la liberté
de conscience,
le droit d'apprendre.
Ce que j'ai retenu
de plus fort,
c'est un cri, fût-il sourd,
fût-il diffus, "laissez-nous
apprendre,
laissez-nous grandir,
nous aurons
perdu
si nous ne pouvons pas faire
germer
ces grains de savoir."
L'hydre terroriste
voudrait les enfermer
dans l'ignorance
et nous empêcher d'apprendre,
d'être nous et de savoir
le transmettre
à nos enfants.
La question est simple et immense.
Comment aider tous
les jeunes de France
et comment appuyer
leurs enseignants,
à mettre des mots
sur ces drames
pour pouvoir
les surmonter
encore plus fort?
Comment soutenir
toute la communauté éducative
pour que toute notre école
soit le creuset
de notre République?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Madame la présidente
Isabelle Rauch,
vous avez rappelé
à travers vos mots
et ceux d'élèves
de votre circonscription
la mission absolue
de l'école: former
des républicains
et des citoyens éclairés.
Cela implique, y compris
dans des drames tels
que celui que nous avons vécu,
que l'école
soit au rendez-vous
pour accueillir
les élèves
et mettre des mots
sur ce qui s'est
passé, pour échanger
avec eux.
J'ai ressenti,
vendredi soir, le besoin
de la communauté
enseignante,
et plus globalement
des personnels
de l'école, de bénéficier
d'un temps dédié
pour pouvoir
préparer ce retour
des élèves, pour pouvoir
porter le deuil,
car il pèse le plus lourd
sur nos enseignants
qui ont perdu l'un
des leurs, pour préparer
le retour des élèves
et préparer ensemble
les meilleurs mots
pour les accueillir
et répondre à leurs questions.
Ce temps leur avait manqué
après l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty.
J'ai tenu à ce qu'ils puissent
en disposer
après l'assassinat
de Dominique Bernard.
Je me suis rendu
dans plusieurs établissements,
hier, et j'ai pu
mesurer que ce temps
avait été utile,
cela leur avait permis,
aux enseignants,
de mettre ensemble
les mots
sur ce qui s'est passé,
pour accueillir leurs élèves.
Je me suis rendu,
avec la Première ministre,
dans un collège
pour un temps d'hommage
et de recueillement.
Nous avons échangé
avec les enseignants.
Vous posez
la question concrète
de ce qui est mis
en place
pour les soutenir d'un point
de vue psychologique.
J'ai mis en place
les dispositifs d'écoute
et d'accompagnement
qui avaient été mis
en place lors de l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty,
dont une cellule
psychologique
toute la journée
et toute la semaine
et une cellule
d'écoute académique
au plus près
des enseignants
pour les accompagner.
C'est fondamentalement
que nous devons accompagner
les enseignants
dans leur mission
qui est de former
des citoyens éclairés.
Il est beaucoup
d'endroits où ils peinent
à le faire.
Les pressions sont fortes.
Vous pouvez compter
sur ma détermination
pour être au rendez-vous
de cette responsabilité absolue.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame
la présidente
Marine Le Pen.
- Marine Le Pen: Merci.
Madame la Première
ministre,
après ce nouveau drame
dans notre pays,
j'ai une pensée
pour les proches
de Dominique Bernard
et pour les blessés,
dont l'employé
qui s'est dressé face
à la barbarie,
mais aussi à l'égard
des professeurs.
Nous sommes législateurs,
comptables
de l'efficacité
des réponses apportées
à ces drames.
Pourquoi annoncer l'expulsion
des étrangers inscrits
et pas avant?
La moitié des attentats
depuis 2007
sont des faits d'étrangers.
Pourquoi ne pas expulser tous
les étrangers islamistes,
qu'ils soient
en situation légale
ou illégale?
Ils sont des ennemis de la France.
Pourquoi ne pas étendre
les expulsions
à ceux qui ont commis
des crimes
et des délits
à leur sortie de prison?
Qu'est-ce qui justifie
de garder
ces personnes sur notre sol?
Pourquoi tromper
les Français pour vendre
votre future loi
sur l'immigration
en faisant croire
que le droit actuel
ne nous permettrait pas
d'expulser
des terroristes
comme le terroriste
en question,
alors que le droit
vous permettrait de le faire?
Cela est indiqué
par l'article 631
par une loi
qui est compatible
avec l'article 33,
alinéa 2 de la convention
de Genève.
Vous faites croire
que votre incapacité
est la conséquence
des lois
alors qu'elle est due
à votre absence
de volonté réelle
et probablement
à une forme de crainte
qui vous empêche
de lutter contre les idéologies
islamistes
qui se répandent
et tuent
dans notre pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs,
madame Marine
Le Pen, vendredi
dernier, un professeur
de lettres du lycée
Gambetta d'Arras,
Dominique Bernard,
a été assassiné
par un terroriste islamiste,
en écho tragique
à l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty
il y a trois ans.
Ces moments graves
sont révélateurs.
Ils nous obligent
d'abord à un peu
de dignité.
Madame la présidente
Marine Le Pen,
depuis 2022,
à chaque crise,
vous vous êtes illustrée
par votre silence.
Aujourd'hui, le naturel
revient au galop.
Alors que la France
est en deuil,
que l'école est touchée
et qu'un enseignant
est mort,
vous vous lancez
dans des polémiques politiciennes.
Vous jetez des anathèmes.
Vous multipliez
les mises en cause.
Alors que le terrorisme
frappe
et que la situation
internationale
est préoccupante,
vous refusez ce matin-même l'unité
de notre pays.
Madame la présidente
Le Pen,
dans les moments
graves, je crois
dans la cohésion
nationale et l'action.
Avec mon gouvernement,
je suis déterminée.
Face aux menaces
qui pèsent
sur notre pays,
nous sommes fermes.
Nous sommes fermes
dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme.
Depuis 2017,
nous avons accordé
des moyens inédits
à nos services
de renseignements
et à notre justice,
des moyens qui ont permis
de déjouer 43 attentats
depuis 6 ans.
Nous sommes fermes
depuis le 7 octobre
et l'attaque terroriste
contre Israël renforçant
la sécurité
des lieux sensibles
et en procédant
à l'interpellation
de plus de 100 individus
en lien direct
avec des actes
antisémites ou d'apologie
du terrorisme.
Nous sommes fermes
pour la sécurité
de nos écoles.
J'ai réhaussé
la protection Vigipirate.
La sécurité des écoles
a été renforcée.
Face aux étrangers
radicalisés
sur notre territoire,
nous luttons.
En 6 ans, plus de 900
étrangers fichés
ont été expulsés.
Etre ferme, c'est renforcer
notre arme juridique.
C'est l'un des objectifs
de notre projet
de loi immigration.
Quand certains pensent
à la polémique,
je veux pour ma part
dire mon soutien
aux agents de services
de renseignement,
aux enquêteurs,
à nos policiers,
gendarmes,
à nos militaires mobilisés
dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme.
Devant vous, je l'affirme
une nouvelle fois,
face aux drames,
notre force,
c'est notre unité,
le respect
de nos valeurs républicaines
et la cohésion nationale
avec notre de gouvernement.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Sacha Houlié.
- Sacha Houlié:
Monsieur le ministre
des Outre-mer,
un autre professeur
est tombé sous les coups
de couteau
d'un terroriste islamiste.
Je veux avoir une pensée
pour Dominique Bernard,
ses collègues,
ses proches, sa famille
et toute la communauté éducative.
Je veux aussi
avoir une pensée
pour nos amis belges
et suédois, frappés
par un attentat
terroriste hier soir.
Je veux saluer,
en tant que président
de la délégation parlementaire
au renseignement,
le travail des services
qui empêchent
la commission d'attentats.
Les services qui,
en dépit des critiques
de certains,
résistent et apportent
toute la sécurité nécessaire
à la population.
C'est toute l'Assemblée
nationale
qui doit les soutenir.
Vous nous avez interrogés
sur les moyens
de ses services.
La délégation parlementaire
au renseignement
va proposer d'élargir
les algorithmes utiles
à ses services.
Vous avez interrogé ce service
en matière d'immigration.
Notre projet
est radical
sur tous les aspects,
en termes de justice.
Il propose de régulariser
les travailleurs
dans les métiers en tension.
Il est radical
en termes de fermeté
pour expulser
ceux qui n'ont rien
à faire sur notre sol.
Il n'y a pas de temps à perdre.
Il y a le retrait
et le non renouvellement
des titres pour le non-respect
aux valeurs
de la République.
Voilà des dispositions
que nous pouvons adopter.
Quand pourrons-nous examiner
ces dispositions?
Allez-vous accélérer
le calendrier?
Allez-vous nous permettre
d'examiner
les moyens que certains
vous réclament,
notamment à droite,
mais qu'ils se privent
de nous permettre d'examiner?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur
le président Sacha Houlié,
merci d'avoir remercié
les agents
de la DGSI, qui,
méticuleusement,
travaillent pour la sécurité
des Français
et déjouent des attentats
sur le sol national.
Merci pour leur travail.
Applaudissements
Merci de souligner
aussi les moyens
que nous leur donnons.
La prochaine fois,
madame Le Pen ferait mieux
de voter
les dispositions concernant
le renseignement
plutôt que d'inventer
des problèmes.
Il faut voter les réserves
dans le public
qui ont été proposées
pour expulser
tous les délinquants que la loi
empêche d'expulser.
Tout cela est dans la loi
immigration.
Veux-t-on que tous
les étrangers
sur le sol national apprennent
à parler français?
C'est aussi dans la loi
immigration.
Veux-t-on que le ministre
de l'Intérieur puisse retirer
leur titre de séjour
aux personnes
qui ne respectent pas
les valeurs
de la République?
C'est aussi dans la loi.
Votons pour pouvoir expulser
les délinquants étrangers,
pour laisser aux législateurs
la possibilité
de prendre leurs responsabilités.
Nous avons un texte
de loi
qui fait cela.
Il doit y avoir des limites
au manque
de responsabilité.
Vous pouvez modifier
la Constitution
si vous le souhaitez,
mais il faut donner
les moyens aux préfets
et au ministre
de l'Intérieur
de protéger les Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
S'il vous plaît...
La parole est à monsieur
le président Boris Vallaud.
- Boris Vallaud:
Madame la Première ministre,
trois ans après Samuel Paty,
Dominique Bernard,
professeur de lettres,
a été assassiné
par un terroriste islamique.
Je veux dire ici
l'horreur
que cela nous inspire.
Nous pensons à ses proches
et aux élèves
du lycée Gambetta,
nous pensons
à nos professeurs et personnels
de l'Education nationale.
Dominique Bernard
a aujourd'hui un visage,
celui de la France.
Par la voix
de ses collègues,
de ses élèves, nous savons
le professeur aimé
qu'il était,
le pédagogue passionné,
féru de culture,
l'homme attentif
aux autres et généreux.
Le meilleur de l'homme,
le meilleur
de l'école.
Celle qui instruit,
celle qui élève
les esprits
et cherche la vérité,
qui rend libre.
Madame la Première
ministre, notre devoir
est de faire bloc.
Parce que les écoles doivent
rester l'asile inviolable
où les querelles des hommes
ne pénètrent pas,
nous refusons
qu'elle soit un champ
de bataille.
Ils ne régleront pas
à eux seuls
les problèmes
de notre temps
et de notre société.
Ils accomplissent
leurs missions
chaque jour.
Ne cédons pas au procès facile
de l'école prétendument
impuissante.
Il faut entendre
leurs inquiétudes,
leurs peurs.
Ils se savent désormais
être des cibles.
Entendons leurs attentes,
leurs difficultés
et répondons
à nos professeurs:
"Oui, nous vous entendons."
Soyons acharnés
dans le travail et l'action,
inscrivons nos politiques
dans la durée.
Ne cédons rien au terrorisme.
Ne cédons rien
à l'obscurantisme,
au fanatisme.
Défendons les valeurs
de la République.
Je vous sais mobilisée.
Vous pouvez compter
sur notre soutien
de républicains.
Quelles sont vos chantiers
prioritaires
pour assurer la sécurité
de nos enseignants?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame la Première
ministre, à vous.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Monsieur le président
Boris Vallaud, c'était finalement
à dessein que les islamistes
s'en prennent
à notre école.
L'école, c'est la promesse
républicaine.
C'est là où l'on combat
les inégalités,
où le goût de la liberté
se transmet
et où la jeunesse se forme.
C'est l'école
de nos enseignants
et de toute la communauté
éducative.
Je veux de nouveau
leur rendre hommage,
leur dire
mon soutien et celui
de mon gouvernement.
Ils sont les visages
de la transmission,
du savoir et de la République.
Nous protégeons nos enseignants.
Nous protégeons nos écoles.
Depuis 6 ans, aux côtés
des collectivités,
nous avons investi
pour mieux protéger
nos établissements scolaires.
Ces derniers jours,
j'ai réhaussé
la posture Vigipirate.
Transmettre
la connaissance ne peut
se faire dans la peur.
Je sais
les responsabilités
que votre groupe
a su prendre face
au terrorisme.
Je connais son attachement
aux valeurs républicaines
et sa volonté
de lutter
contre toutes les haines.
Dans un tel contexte,
nous avons besoin d'unité,
de cohésion nationale,
d'un message clair face
aux terroristes,
qu'ils frappent
en France, en Belgique
ou en Israël.
Monsieur le président
Vallaud,
j'ai souvent parlé
de l'arc républicain
et des personnes
qui s'en excluent
par leurs propos ou leurs actes.
Après les déclarations
de ce matin, chacun sait
sans équivoque
qui défend
la République
et ses valeurs
et qui ne les partage pas
dans les groupes politiques.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
David Guiraud.
- David Guiraud: Merci.
Madame la Première
ministre, nous n'avons
plus que quelques heures
pour éviter
le pire en Palestine.
Ce samedi,
la rapporteur spéciale
de l'ONU dans les territoires
palestiniens occupés
a déclaré que les Palestiniens
de Gaza courent
le risque d'un nettoyage
ethnique massif.
Les Palestiniens
sont sous le coup
d'un ordre d'évacuation
que Médecins
du monde qualifie d'impensable
et d'irréaliste.
Le monde a été averti.
C'est toute une nation
qui est responsable.
Le président israélien
annonce une punition
contre les Palestiniens,
pourtant interdite
par le droit international.
Israël a déjà bafoué
plusieurs fois
ce droit international.
Nous nous dirigeons
vers une catastrophe humanitaire
et diplomatique.
Cette catastrophe,
c'est l'anéantissement
de la solution à deux Etats.
Les Palestiniens ne retrouveront
probablement jamais
leurs terres.
Il faudrait appeler
un cessez-le-feu humanitaire
dans la bande de Gaza.
Il faudrait condamner
les attaques terroristes
du Hamas.
La France va-t-elle soutenir
ces résolutions?
La France
ne prend pas ses responsabilités.
Nous devons exiger
un cessez-le-feu
pour nos compatriotes
franco-israéliens otages
du Hamas.
Comment comptez-vous protéger
nos compatriotes bloqués
à Gaza?
Nous ne pouvons pas soutenir
inconditionnellement
ce que fait l'Etat
israélien à Gaza.
La France
est trop silencieuse
sur ce nettoyage ethnique.
La vie
d'un Palestinien
ne vaut pas moins que celle
d'un Israélien.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
la secrétaire d'Etat chargée
du développement,
de la francophonie
et des partenariats
internationaux.
- Merci.
Je vous prie d'abord
de bien vouloir excuser
la ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères.
Elle est en Moldavie.
Je vous rappelle
qu'Israël a été frappé
par une offensive
terroriste sans précédent
dans son histoire.
Je vous rappelle que le Hamas,
organisation terroriste,
est entrée en Israël
pour tuer des juifs,
des hommes, des femmes,
des enfants,
et que le Hamas,
organisation terroriste,
est une organisation
qui a perpétré
un massacre.
Tout le monde a vu
les images ignobles
qui nous parviennent d'Israël.
Je vous rappelle
aussi que le Hamas
a pris en otage
des personnes âgées,
des enfants.
Je vous rappelle
enfin
que parmi les victimes
de cette barbarie,
il y a de nombreux Français.
21 Français ont perdu la vie.
Plusieurs autres
Français,
dont nous sommes
sans nouvelles,
sont probablement
retenus en otage
à Gaza.
Dans ce contexte,
la position
de la France est claire.
Elle a été rappelée
à de nombreuses reprises
à tous les niveaux.
La ministre
l'a rappelé aussi
ces trois derniers jours.
Face à l'horreur,
Israël a le droit
de se défendre.
Israël doit le faire
en préservant
les populations
civiles,
et dans le cadre
du droit international
et du droit humanitaire,
qui doivent
être pleinement respectés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Véronique Louwagie.
- Véronique Louwagie: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre délégué
aux comptes publics.
Dans quelques instants,
nous débuterons l'examen
du texte du PLF 2024.
C'est une occasion
manquée qui accroît
le décrochage
français et fait
de la France l'un
des pires élèves
de l'Europe.
Nous avons le taux
de prélèvement obligatoire,
44,1% du PIB,
le plus élevé
après le Danemark.
Notre taux
de dépenses publiques
est supérieur de 8
points à celui
de la moyenne de la zone euro.
En 2024, seuls
trois pays auront
un déficit plus élevé
que le nôtre.
Nous somes
le troisième pays
le plus endetté d'Europe.
Au moment de l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron,
en 2017...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je demande aux gens
de quitter l'hémicycle
dans le silence.
- Véronique Louwagie: Merci.
Au moment de l'élection
d'Emmanuel Macron,
sept pays avaient une dette
plus élevée
que la France.
Il n'en reste plus que deux.
Nos finances
sont plus que jamais dégradées
et votre gouvernement
renonce à la baisse
des impôts pour les ménages
et les entreprises.
Il revient
sur la suppression
de la CVAE dès 2024,
pourtant votée l'an dernier.
La Première ministre
a annoncé une diminution
de la masse salariale.
Voulez-vous entrer
dans l'histoire
de France, monsieur
le ministre,
en devenant le premier ministre
du Budget qui traduit
une diminution conséquence
des défenses publiques,
du déficit
et de l'endettement?
Alors que le président
avait promis
la fin de l'abondance,
pourquoi
avoir repoussé encore plus tard
le rétablissement
de nos comptes?
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Thomas Cazenave.
- Thomas Cazenave: Merci.
Madame la députée
Véronique Louwagie,
vous savez
que nous défendons un projet
de budget qui vise à ramener
le déficit public
à 4,4% en 2024
et à repasser
sous les 3% en 2027.
Nous pouvons le faire.
Avant les crises
que nous avons traversées,
nous avions ramené
notre déficit à baisser.
Nous avons protégé
les Français
et les salariés.
C'est pour cela qu'il a augmenté.
Est-ce que notre pays
continue à créer
des emplois?
Oui.
Est-ce que nous
avons une croissance
plus élevée
que nos partenaires européens?
Oui.
L'Allemagne rentre
en récession
et pas nous.
Nous avons bien fait de protéger.
Est-ce que, pour autant,
il faut s'engager
dans la réduction
des déficits publics?
Oui, en faisant des économies.
Nous faisons 16 milliards
d'euros d'économies
en 2024.
Nous supprimons
progressivement le bouclier
et les dispositifs exceptionnels.
Dans le même temps,
vous nous demandez
de remettre
une ristourne carburant
qui nous coûterait 10
milliards d'euros.
Attention aux injonctions
contradictoires.
Nous devons continuer à faire
des réformes structurelles.
Nous sommes à l'écoute
de vos propositions.
Aidez-nous à voter
les réformes structurelles
qui nous permettent
de faire des économies.
Comme la réforme des retraites.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Nadia Hai.
- Nadia Hai:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le ministre
de l'Education nationale,
il paraît qu'on s'habitue
à la pire barbarie
et pas plus, aujourd'hui.
Il paraît qu'on s'habitue
aux horreurs
que l'on vit là,
mais l'innocent
que l'on tue,
je ne m'y habitue pas.
Quand cela a été écrit
pour Samuel Paty,
nous étions loin
d'imaginer
que cela serait
seulement le premier.
Malgré cela, l'islamisme
a encore frappé
à Arras.
Chacun de nous a revu,
dans les visages
de Samuel Paty
et de Dominique Bernard,
les visages de nos professeurs.
C'est cet espoir de l'unité
que le terrorisme islamiste
souhaite atteindre
en faisant régner
la peur, la terreur
et la fatalité.
Il se trompe.
La peur
n'est pas dans la grammaire
de la nation.
Le renoncement non plus.
C'est cet espoir
et cette unité
que nos enseignants
vont continuer
à transmettre à nos enfants.
Nous souhaitons exprimer
ici et maintenant
notre profonde
reconnaissance,
à ces enseignants.
Hier, nous avons tous
constaté le dévouement
et l'engagement
du corps professoral.
Nous les avons vus au collège
de Conflans-Sainte-Honorine.
J'ai vu le regard digne
des professeurs.
J'ai vu qu'ils portent
la force nécessaire
pour aider nos enfants
à traverser
cette épreuve.
Cette communauté
éducative a besoin
de ressources pour dépasser
les souffrances psychologiques,
lorsqu'ils doivent
faire face
à des provocations indignes.
Comment ces moments
de recueillement
ont-ils été observés?
Quelles sont les ressources
mises
à disposition
de l'équipe éducative
pour traverser
cette épreuve et montrer
que la France aime ses enfants?
En France, personne
ne doit avoir peur.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Gabriel Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Madame la députée
Nadia Hai,
vous êtes élue des Yvelines.
Nous étions ensemble hier
à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine
avec la Première ministre.
Vous savez
plus que tout autre,
parce que vous avez vécu
l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty au sein
de votre territoire,
combien ce traumatisme
est lourd
pour les enseignants.
Hier, c'est une nouvelle
onde de choc
qui est arrivée
à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine.
Sur la question
de l'accompagnement psychologique,
j'ai répondu tout à l'heure.
Vous savez combien
il est important
de sentir la nation
toute entière
à leurs côtés.
Nous avons souhaité
qu'hier, à 14h,
la nation entière
retienne son souffle
en hommage à Dominique Bernard,
à Samuel Paty,
à tous les enseignants de France.
Ce moment est important.
J'avais été clair
et ferme, à la veille
de ce moment,
en indiquant qu'il y aurait
une tolérance zéro
pour la moindre contestation
ou la moindre provocation,
à l'occasion
de ces moments.
Je veux le dire,
dans l'écrasante majorité
des cas, ce moment
de recueillement s'est déroulé
dans la plus profonde dignité.
Je veux saluer
les enseignants
et les élèves.
Mais je dois le dire
aussi, 179 élèves
ont fait un autre choix,
celui de perturber
ce recueillement,
de provoquer l'école
et d'insulter la mémoire
de nos professeurs.
Notre nation et notre école
ne peuvent tolérer cela.
Conformément aux engagements
que j'avais pris
devant les Français,
ce sont 179 dossiers
qui partent aujourd'hui
contre ces élèves.
Il y aura 179 procédures
disciplinaires.
Une partie d'entre
eux relève de l'apologie
du terrorisme.
Pour eux, je demande
l'exclusion
de ces élèves.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Applaudissements
La parole est à monsieur
Alexandre Sabatou.
- Alexandre Sabatou: Merci.
Cette question s'adresse
à madame Colonna.
Vendredi dernier,
la présidente
de la Commission
européenne s'est imposée
dans le déplacement
de l'Europe en Israël.
Pourquoi?
Personne ne le sait
car la diplomatie
ne fait pas partie
de ses prérogatives.
Elle n'a reçu
aucun mandat
pour s'y rendre
et encore
moins pour engager la parole
des pays européens.
Malgré cela,
elle a eu un entretien
avec le Premier
ministre israélien
et fait des déclarations au nom
de l'Union Européenne.
En omettant d'évoquer
l'obligation d'Israël
de respecter le droit
international
dans sa riposte
contre le Hamas,
toute la diplomatie
de la France
et de l'Europe est fragilisée.
Encore une fois,
la Commission européenne
a outrepassé
ses pouvoirs
et nous en payons le prix.
Comme toujours,
la Commission européenne,
jalouse du pouvoir
des nations souveraines,
s'arroge de nouvelles
prérogatives,
comme elle l'a fait
sur la santé
avec le Covid.
Elle le fait aujourd'hui
sur la diplomatie.
En abandonnant
vos compétences
à la commission,
vos pouvoirs,
vous abandonnez
la voix de la France.
Aujourd'hui, autrefois
immense nation
de la diplomatie,
la France est devenue
un simple télégraphiste
de l'Union Européenne.
Pourquoi avez-vous invité
Ursula Von der Leyen récemment?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Chrysoula Zacharopoulou.
- Chrysoula Zacharopoulou: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs,
monsieur le député
Alexandre Sabatou,
s'agissant
de la visite de madame
Ursula Von der Leyen
en Israël,
elle s'exprimait
en tant que présidente
de la Commission européenne.
La position
de l'Union Européenne
est claire.
Elle a été rappelée
par les ministres
des Affaires étrangères
de l'Union Européenne puis
par le Conseil européen,
c'est-à-dire
les chefs d'Etats
et de gouvernements.
L'Union Européenne
a ainsi condamné,
avec une grande fermeté,
les attaques terroristes
du Hamas en Israël.
Elle a rappelé
les droits d'Israël
à se défendre conformément
au droit international.
Elle a réaffirmé
l'importance d'assurer
la protection
de tous les civils,
à tout moment, conformément
au droit international
humanitaire.
La commission a appelé
le Hamas à libérer
tous les otages.
Elle a aussi rappelé
toute l'importance d'empêcher
une escalade régionale.
Il faut que les deux Etats
coexistent.
C'est dans cet esprit
que Catherine Colonna s'est
rendue, à la demande
du président,
en Israël le 15
octobre puis en Egypte
et au Liban.
S'agissant plus spécifiquement
de l'aide européenne,
la position
de l'Union Européenne
est claire.
Il faut veiller
à ce que cette aide
ne bénéficie pas au Hamas
mais directement
aux populations palestiniennes.
C'est dans ce contexte que madame
Ursula Von der Leyen
a annoncé la mise en place
d'un pont aérien humanitaire
vers Gaza via l'Egypte.
Les chefs des Etats de l'Union
Européenne pourront revenir
sur ces sujets cet après-midi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le député?
-
Alexandre Sabatou:
Vous ne répondez pas
à la question.
Même sur vos rangs, cela divise.
Cette prise de parole
a été dénoncée.
Mais il n'y
a pas qu'à la NUPES
que tout s'écroule.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Mickaël Cosson.
- Mickaël Cosson:
Ma question s'adresse
à à la ministre des Familles.
Nous sommes très nombreux
sur des bancs
à considérer
que c'est l'honneur
de notre Nos aînés
vivent dans l'angoisse
de ne plus vivre sereinement.
Nos EHPAD sont à bout de souffle.
Les équilibres
financiers
ne sont plus assurés.
Nos personnels
souffrent au quotidien.
La résignation l'emporte
sur la vocation.
Nous nous devons
d'apporter une réponse
à ces inquiétudes,
une réponse
qui soit à la hauteur
du défi auquel
notre pays est confronté.
D'ici 2050, le nombre
de personnes âgées
de 75 à 84 ans
dans notre pays connaîtra
une hausse de près de 50%,
rendant indispensable
une réponse ambitieuse
à la problématique
du grand âge.
Les parlementaires se mobilisent.
L'ensemble
de mes collègues,
quelles que soient
leurs sensibilités politiques,
partagent cette préoccupation.
Nous avons créé
la cinquième branche
en 2020.
Aujourd'hui, vous portez
une réforme ambitieuse
du financement des EHPAD.
Il nous faudra traiter
la dépendance demandant
toute son ampleur
et sa complexité,
loin des rustines,
comme un énième crédit d'impôt,
loin des procès d'intention
et des postures,
nous devons
des réponses
à toutes ces familles.
Madame la ministre,
pouvez-vous
nous dire avec quels moyens
vous comptez agir
pour que nos aînés
puissent bien vieillir?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Aurore Bergé.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député
Mickaël Cosson,
merci pour la question
qui permet
de rappeler l'engagement
des députés
de la majorité sur cette question.
Nous nous réunissions
dès cet été
avec des maire -- maires
des Côtes-d'Armor
et du Finistère,
vous-même et un certain nombre
de parlementaires engagés
dans les territoires.
Le choc démographique
auquel notre pays
va faire face
est une des plus grandes
transitions à laquelle
la société doit
se préparer.
Ce n'est pas juste
la question des EHPAD
et des modèles économiques.
C'est l'adaptation
de toute la société.
Comment garantir à nos personnes
âgées vieillissantes
de pouvoir rester
à domicile,
puisque c'est d'abord
leur première volonté?
Comment garantir
leurs droits
tout au long
de leur parcours de vie?
Comment faire en sorte
que nos EHPAD soient mieux
organisés?
Comment avoir un parcours
résidentiel
entre le domicile et l'EHPAD,
et l'inclusion pleine
et entière à l'ensemble
de la société?
C'est le défi
de l'adaptation
de la société au vieillissement.
On voit ça comme un déclin.
Ce n'est pas un déclin,
c'est une formidable nouvelle
que nous ayons
une espérance de vie
en bonne santé qui continue
à progresser d'année
en année.
C'est la capacité
que nous avons à faire
en sorte que nos aînés
soient inclus
dans la société,
partagent leur expérience,
soient des élus
de la République,
soient des milliers
de bénévoles, soient
des grands-parents.
Nous avons besoin de financements.
Nous avons voté la création
de la branche autonomie.
Je souhaite engager
une réforme ambitieuse,
car c'est ici que nous aurons
de véritables modalités
de financement
sur le long terme
en lien avec les départements.
Nous ne pouvons pas le faire
seuls.
Il y a aussi
ce que les collectivités locales
font.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Nathalie Bassire.
- Nathalie Bassire:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre des Outre-mer.
Samedi dernier,
un amendement signé
par le rapporteur
général du budget
a été déposé en vue
de l'examen du PLF 2024
en séance publique,
visant notamment
à supprimer le bénéfice
de l'aide fiscale
en faveur des biens destinés
à la consommation
des particuliers,
surtout les meublés touristiques
individuels
et touristiques,
sur les véhicules
de tourisme de location,
soit un total de 160
millions d'euros
en moins pour l'activité
et l'emploi.
A-t-on mesuré l'ampleur
des conséquences économiques
et sociales sur nos territoires
ultramarins, sachant qu'aucune
justification sérieuse
n'a été fournie,
ni la moindre
analyse des impacts
sur l'emploi
et sur la création de valeur?
Je ne parle
même pas du problème
du fond et de méthode
que posent
de telles annonces si brutales.
Sans concertation
avec les acteurs
du monde économique,
notamment ultramarin.
Comme c'est regrettable!
Est-ce
ainsi que vous justifiez
des décisions pareilles?
L'amendement conduit
à la suppression
du bénéfice de l'aide fiscale
à l'investissement
sur les secteurs
d'activité importants
de nos économies ultramarines.
Un dialogue constructif
aurait permis
de calibrer des réponses
techniques, permettant
de répondre à certains enjeux
légitimes soulevés
par les pouvoirs
publics,
sans pour autant
supprimer un pan entier
de l'aide fiscale en faveur
d'activités structurantes.
Pouvez-vous, s'il
vous plaît, communiquer
sans délai
à la représentation nationale
les analyses
d'impact des mesures
que vous proposez?
Analyses indispensables
pour éclairer
notre vote.
En l'absence
de ces éléments,
allez-vous reporter l'examen
de cet amendement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Philippe Vigier.
- Philippe Vigier:
Madame la députée,
merci de me donner
l'occasion de dire
que le budget
des outre-mer, c'est 7%
de plus qu'en 2022.
Le gouvernement
va financer beaucoup
plus les outre-mer,
qui en ont beaucoup besoin.
C'est plus d'argent
pour le logement,
50 millions
d'euros de plus,
pour la ligne budgétaire unique.
Beaucoup plus d'argent
pour les collectivités.
40 millions
de plus pour accompagner
les collectivités
pour les aides financières.
Si je parle également
des écoles,
c'est 300 millions
d'euros de plus.
Vous passez tout sous silence.
Vous m'interrogez
sur une niche fiscale.
Elles sont maintenues
jusqu'en 2028.
On va corriger
celles qui sont inefficaces.
Je tiens à dire que les véhicules
utilitaires continueront
de bénéficier
de la défiscalisation,
pas les véhicules individuels.
On conservera
tout ce qui produit
de la valeur, pareil
pour les équipements touristiques.
Ils continueront
de bénéficier
de la défiscalisation.
On continuera
à chercher un chemin
pour les personnes
qui louent leur logement.
On a voulu l'efficacité,
notamment
pour la transition énergétique.
Toutes les rénovations
thermiques seront soumises
à la défiscalisation,
ce qui n'existait
pas avant.
Pour les autoconsommations
et les équipements
photovoltaïques,
ça n'existait pas.
Le pouvoir d'achat
a guidé nos mesures.
Je le dis devant le ministre
du Budget,
nous trouvons ensemble
les solutions
pour celles et ceux,
notamment les loueurs
de voitures,
qui seraient pénalisés.
C'est un budget
à l'offensive
qui va aider les territoires
ultramarins.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Franck Allisio.
- Franck Allisio:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
à Bruno Le Maire,
le ministre de l'Economie.
Jeudi prochain,
aura lieu la 21e édition
de la fête des entreprises
de l'opération J'aime
ma boîte.
Je saisis cette occasion
pour saluer
tous nos entrepreneurs,
nos salariés,
toute cette France
qui travaille dur,
qui crée de la richesse
et qui innove.
Cette France
qui bosse a d'autant
plus de mérite
qu'elle essaie de réussir
malgré votre politique,
une politique
qui fait de la France
la championne
des impôts et des taxes.
C'est la France
de la bureaucratie,
de la dette de demain.
Nous savons,
depuis le Covid-19,
qu'Emmanuel Macron
vous encourage
à emmerder les Français.
Vous en appelez,
sur les plateaux
de télévision,
à simplifier
tout ce qui pourra l'être
pour les entrepreneurs,
sans jamais joindre
la parole aux actes.
Bruno oublie
tout simplement
que Le Maire est ministre
de l'Economie
depuis près d'un septennat.
Même déni de réalité
lorsque vous affirmez
que les impôts
ont baissé
alors qu'ils ont augmenté,
en valeur relative
et absolue.
A quand votre reconnexion
avec le réel?
A quand la fin
de ce double discours?
de cette politique mortifère?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député
Allisio, 11 milliards
de baisses d'impôts
sur les sociétés
depuis 2017,
une baisse d'impôts
sur les sociétés de 33% à 25%.
Pendant que d'aucuns rigolaient
et rigolent encore,
qui a baissé les impôts
des entreprises
depuis 6 ans?
Qui a baissé les impôts
sur les sociétés?
Qui a baissé,
dans des moments compliqués,
les impôts de production?
Qui enclenche une baisse
de 9 milliards
sur la CVAE
alors que c'était au coeur
du problème
de compétitivité français?
Savez-vous
quel est le différentiel
d'impôt de production
entre la France
et l'Allemagne?
Il est facile de pérorer.
Sur une paire de chaussures
de 60 euros, avez-vous
une idée
du différentiel
qu'il y avait entre la France
et l'Allemagne?
C'était 2 euros en France,
c'est 30 centimes
en Allemagne.
On cherche
où est la compétitivité?
On cherche où sont les marges
pour redonner
du pouvoir d'achat
et augmenter
les salaires,
comme ça a été fait
par les entreprises
françaises
depuis un an?
Ils étaient présents,
les gisements
de croissance.
La baisse d'impôts
sur les sociétés,
la baisse des impôts
de production,
ce sont des choses
qui ont été faites.
Quelle est la réalité,
aujourd'hui?
Il y a sept ans,
lorsqu'on est arrivés,
on nous disait de nous aider.
Qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit,
dans vos circonscriptions?
Aidez-nous à trouver des salariés.
Nos PME sont compétitives.
Quel est le pays
d'Europe qui aura
une croissance positive,
là où l'Allemagne
est en récession?
C'est nous,
grâce à notre majorité.
Pendant que ça
papote,
il y en a qui bossent
depuis six ans
pour soutenir les PME de France.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
- Franck Allisio:
Dans les faits,
votre bilan,
c'est plus d'impôts
et plus de dette.
Macron rime avec Mélenchon!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Matthias Tavel.
- Matthias Tavel:
Vous avez tenu,
hier, une conférence
sociale
avec les représentants
des salariés
du patronat.
Pour être à la hauteur
de l'attente
des Français,
elle aurait dû porter
sur le financement
des retraites
et l'abrogation
de la retraite à 64 ans,
comme le veut la majorité
de nos concitoyens
et de cette Assemblée
nationale,
en dépit de toutes vos manoeuvres
antidémocratiques.
Elle aurait dû acter
la hausse du SMIC,
l'indexation des salaires
sur l'inflation,
la fin des cadeaux
aux actionnaires.
A la place, vous n'avez
inventé qu'un comité
sur les rémunérations.
Encore une fois,
vous récidivez
dans votre préférence
actionnarial,
où les Français attendent
la préférence salariale.
Vous n'avez toujours pas renoncé
à ponctionner 1 milliard d'euros
dans les caisses
des retraites complémentaires
des salariés du privé,
malgré l'opposition unanime
du patronat et des syndicats
de salariés.
Vous vous apprêtez ainsi
à racketter 13 millions
de retraités,
alors que le Conseil
d'orientation
des retraites dit
que les pensions
complémentaires
vont baisser.
Quand il s'agit
d'exiger un peu
plus du patronat,
vous renvoyez
tout à plus tard.
Quand il s'agit
de voler 2 ans de vie
ou 1 milliard d'euros
aux travailleurs,
vous frappez vite et fort.
Vous êtes plus doués
pour faire
les poches
des Français
que pour les remplir.
Il suffirait
pourtant de revenir
sur les exonérations
de cotisations sociales ou,
a minima, de les conditionner
pour dégager
des recettes nouvelles
pour la Sécurité sociale.
Quand allez-vous
enfin conditionner
ces 206 milliards
d'euros annuels
de dette publique aux entreprises?
Allez-vous enfin
renoncer à l'idée
de ponctionner les caisses
de retraite complémentaire
du privé?
Jusqu'à quand allez-vous
préférer
la maltraitance
sociale à la justice
et au progrès?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Carole Grandjean.
- Carole Grandjean:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député Tavel,
vous interrogez
le gouvernement
sur différents sujets.
Vous parlez notamment
de la conférence sociale
que nous engageons
depuis de longs mois
et qui a fait l'objet d'une
conférence sociale.
Sur ce sujet, je veux
dire que la position
du gouvernement n'a pas varié.
Les partenaires sociaux
se sont accordés
sur un ensemble
de dépenses nouvelles,
dont l'indexation
des pensions
et la suppression du bonus-malus.
Ce sont des dépenses
importantes,
avec des effets
pour l'avenir
qui sont financés
par le rendement
de la réforme
des retraites
que nous avons portée.
La réforme
des retraites génère,
pour cette caisse,
plus de 1 milliard d'excédents
à l'horizon 2026
et presque 3 milliards
à l'horizon 2030.
C'est le seul
effet mécanique
de la réforme.
Depuis le début
des concertations fin 2022,
nous avons défendu
un équilibre du système
des retraites,
pour tous les régimes,
à horizon 2030.
C'est en intégrant
les régimes de base
et les régimes
complémentaires
que cela a été fait.
Nous avons fait le choix
de la confiance
dans le dialogue social.
C'est à l'issue
d'une journée riche
en diagnostics
et en prises de position
que nous avons pu,
grâce à la discussion,
faire des annonces
nombreuses
qui sont le résultat
des discussions
avec les partenaires sociaux.
Je pense au dialogue
de branche
qui va être réactivé.
Je pense au calcul
des exonérations
sur la base des minima de branche.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur le rapporteur
général Jean-René Cazeneuve.
- Jean-René Cazeneuve:
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre des Comptes publics.
Nous examinons
à partir d'aujourd'hui
le budget 2024.
Je suis très fier
de soutenir ce texte
qui renforce
le ministère régalien,
à un moment où la menace n'a
jamais été aussi forte,
comme le rappellent
les terribles événements
de la semaine dernière.
Plus de 3 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires
pour nos armées,
1 milliard pour l'Intérieur,
500 millions
pour le ministère
de la Justice.
C'est aussi un PLF
qui renforce
notre transition
écologique, avec 7
milliards d'euros supplémentaires.
Ce sont plus de
possibilités
pour les Français
de changer leur voiture
ou d'isoler leur habitation.
Plus d'argent
pour les collectivités
territoriales
pour rénover leurs écoles
et changer leurs éclairages.
C'est un plan qui protège
le pouvoir d'achat
des Français.
Nous prolongeons le bouclier.
Nous indexons les impôts
sur le revenu.
C'est un budget qui assure
le désendettement
de notre pays,
avec un objectif
à la hausse.
Le débat a été d'une
grande intensité,
même si je regrette
l'alliance des contraires.
Il y a des personnes
qui proposent l'austérité,
avec des taxes et des impôts
supplémentaires.
Les autres parlent
de gabegie,
mais proposent
des amendements qui amènent
des dizaines de milliards
de dépenses supplémentaires.
Notre conviction
est que notre projet
est ambitieux,
équilibré et responsable.
Ma question,
monsieur le ministre,
est liée au fait
que nous traversons
une nouvelle crise
au Moyen-Orient,
avec un impact
sur la croissance mondiale
et sur le prix du pétrole.
Quel pourrait
être l'impact de celle-ci
sur nous?
- Elisabeth Borne:
La parole est à monsieur Thomas
Cazenave.
- Thomas Cazenave:
Vous m'interrogez
sur les conséquences du conflit
au Proche-Orient
sur notre budget.
Nous sommes dans
une situation
où les incertitudes
économiques
sont importantes.
Il est aujourd'hui
trop tôt pour dire
si elle aura
une conséquence
sur notre croissance
et notre inflation.
Nous avons le ralentissement
chinois
et la politique monétaire de taux
d'intérêt élevée.
Ce sont autant
d'incertitudes
sur le climat économique
autour de nous.
Nous avons déjà revu
notre prévision
de croissance à la baisse.
Nous avons aussi maintenu
notre hypothèse d'inflation.
Dans cette période
d'incertitudes,
j'ai une conviction:
il faut poursuivre
le redressement
de nos finances publiques.
Pourquoi?
Ce qui nous a permis
d'affronter
les crises
successives,
c'est que nous avions retrouvé
des marges
de manoeuvre.
Si j'avais un message
dans le climat d'incertitude
dans lequel
nous avançons,
c'est que nous ne devons pas
dévier
de la politique
de redressement
de nos finances publiques.
Nous avons besoin
d'économies, 16 milliards
en 2024.
Nous en avons besoin
dans les années suivantes.
Nous devons continuer
les réformes structurelles.
Les marges
qui nous permettent de mettre
en oeuvre les priorités
rappelées
par le rapporteur
général, c'est aussi
la réforme
de l'assurance-chômage
ou la réforme des retraites.
Nous avons encore besoin
de réformes structurelles
pour redresser
nos finances publiques
et ramener
le déficit public
à moins de 3% d'ici 2027.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Sabrina Sebaihi.
- Sabrina Sebaihi:
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
des Affaires étrangères.
Depuis plusieurs quinquennats,
la politique étrangère
de notre pays tourne
le dos à nos valeurs.
Au Moyen-Orient,
notre influence
et notre voix,
celles d'un pays
non aligné, appartiennent
au 20e siècle.
Nous aurions dû
avoir un discours simple,
la condamnation
du Hamas et le rejet
des représailles aveugles
du gouvernement israélien,
comme l'a fait
le secrétaire de l'ONU.
L'attaque terroriste
du Hamas, l'assassinant
des civils,
a suscité un émoi
et une condamnation
partout
dans le monde.
Près de 800 enfants
palestiniens
ont été tués lors de frappes
israéliennes, aujourd'hui.
Qu'avez-vous dit?
Rien, ou si peu.
Qu'avez-vous dit en réponse
au président israélien
qui a déclaré
qu'il n'y
avait aucun innocent à Gaza?
Rien.
La position de la France
est de considérer
que toute frappe
contre des infrastructures
et des personnes
civiles constitue
un crime de guerre.
Pour être cohérents
avec nos valeurs humanistes
et le droit
international,
ne devrions-nous pas appliquer
ce principe aussi
à Gaza?
Pour le gouvernement d'extrême
droite israélien,
la vie d'un Palestinien vaut
moins qu'un Israélien.
Les personnes qui soutiennent
Benjamin Netanyahou
dans cet hémicycle
font partie
de ce groupe.
J'ai entendu
votre non-réponse
à mon collègue.
Le respect du droit
international s'applique
à tous et implique
de ne pas bombarder
de manière discontinue
des populations civiles,
ou de ne pas couper
d'accès à l'eau
ou à l'électricité
à des populations civiles.
Faites vôtres les mots
du président Chirac:
"Tant que les
Palestiniens
n'ont pas accès..."
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Chrysoula
Zacharopoulou.
- Chrysoula Zacharopoulou:
Madame
la députée, face
à la situation dramatique
au Proche-Orient,
la ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires
étrangères s'est rendue,
à la demande du président
de la République,
à Tel-Aviv,
à Jérusalem, au Caire,
à Beyrouth, d'une
part pour afficher
notre soutien
à Israël, meurtri
dans sa chair
par les terroristes,
d'autre part
pour rappeler l'ensemble
des acteurs de la région
à la responsabilité.
Lors des exactions
et des massacres commis
par le Hamas, 21
Français ont été tués.
Face à l'horreur,
Israël a le droit
de se défendre.
Ils doivent le faire
dans le droit international
et en prenant en compte
la protection
des populations civiles.
La France se tient
également aux côtés
des populations palestiniennes.
Elles ne sont pas
responsables
de la situation.
Il ne faut pas confondre
le Hamas
avec l'ensemble
de la population palestinienne.
Nous sommes très clairs
sur ce point
depuis le premier jour.
De plus, la France
agit pour leur venir
en aide.
Nous avons mis en place,
hier, une aide
de 10 millions d'euros
au bénéfice direct
des populations de Gaza.
Des efforts sont en cours
pour ouvrir
un couloir humanitaire,
pour que l'aide
des Nations Unies
puisse être acheminée
et parvienne aux populations.
Cette aide est prête.
Elle doit
pouvoir passer,
c'est une urgence.
Tous les civils qui veulent
partir doivent pouvoir
le faire.
Le Hamas ne peut pas prendre
en otage
la population.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Temaiti Le Gayic.
- Tematai Le Gayic:
Avec tout le respect
que je vous dois,
madame la Première ministre,
vous êtes-vous
déjà douchée
avec de l'eau saumâtre?
Le silence est d'or.
C'est une eau salée dégorgeant
une odeur nauséabonde.
C'est le quotidien
de l'archipel Tuhamotu
que je représente,
faute d'infrastructures.
Mayotte et la Guadeloupe
font l'actualité
ces derniers
jours,
mais ils ne sont que la partie
immergée d'une crise
qui touche tous les outre-mer.
L'accès à l'eau
potable fait partie
des droits humains
fondamentaux, notamment
sur un texte signé
il y a 43 ans
par la France.
Pénurie et stress hydrique
sont le quotidien
des habitants ultra-marins.
La solution
ne réside pas dans l'envoi
massif de bouteilles d'eau.
Il est vital
de proposer un fonds
dans lequel nos collectivités
territoriales puissent puiser
les financements
supplémentaires
pour rénover
les conduits d'eau,
pour investir
dans des systèmes de filtrage.
Des financements
supplémentaires
sont nécessaires,
particulièrement
en Polynésie.
Les communes
ne peuvent pas lever l'impôt.
Elles sont dépendantes
des fonds
de l'Etat.
Il est inélégant
de ma part d'évoquer
ce sujet sans parler
des ministres
qui font la tournée
des pays respectifs
pour apporter des solutions.
Les solutions
au compte-gouttes
ne sont pas suffisantes.
Combien de fonds
supplémentaires
à ceux qui existent
déjà actuellement,
qui sont insuffisants,
pouvez-vous débloquer
pour soutenir
les investissements
des communes pour une véritable
planification
de l'accès à l'eau
pour tous, partout?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Philippe Vigier.
- Philippe Vigier:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
vous posez une question centrale,
celle de l'eau.
Vous avez raison de le dire.
On parle beaucoup
de Mayotte
et de la Guadeloupe,
mais l'ensemble
des territoires
ultramarins est concerné.
Dans le réchauffement
climatique,
la fourniture d'eau
et notre capacité,
demain, à désaliniser l'eau
est indispensable.
L'Etat a fait des efforts
considérables
depuis 2016.
Des efforts
considérables
qui se sont traduits
par des moyens d'investissement
de l'ordre de 50
millions supplémentaires
chaque année.
On a même mis
des moyens techniques,
des bras, pour accompagner
les collectivités.
Vous savez très bien
que l'affaire
de l'eau, c'est l'affaire
des collectivités
et de l'Etat.
On a mobilisé aussi
l'Office français
de la biodiversité
avec l'Agence
de développement.
On a franchi
un pas supplémentaire:
35 millions d'euros en plus.
Je suis en capacité
de vous dire que,
au moment où je vous parle,
en Guadeloupe,
le président
du département
est en train de signer
avec le préfet
un contrat de 320
millions d'euros.
J'ai répondu à des questions
sur Mayotte, hier.
Nous avons décidé
de prendre en charge
les factures.
Nous allons acheminer
les bouteilles d'eau
en attendant
d'avoir des équipements
structurants
comme ceux auxquels
vous faites référence,
les osmoseurs.
Nous ne laisserons pas tomber
les Français.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Nicolas Metzdorf.
- Nicolas Metzdorf: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à la Première ministre.
La situation
en Nouvelle-Calédonie
est catastrophique.
L'incertitude
institutionnelle a mené
à une perte de 10%
de notre population
depuis cinq ans.
Nous perdons 2
points de PIB par an
et par habitant.
Nos trois usines de nickel
sont en quasi faillite.
Les actionnaires
ont déjà annoncé
qu'ils arrêtaient
de financer les outils
de production.
Alors que le panier
alimentaire reste
à 80% plus élevé qu'en
France métropolitaine.
Madame la Première
ministre,
vous nous avez déjà
beaucoup aidés.
Vous avez versé une subvention
de 33 millions d'euros
il y a quelques semaines
pour rééquilibrer
les comptes sociaux
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Mais vos services mettent
une pression énorme
sur le gouvernement de notre pays.
Nous vivons une semaine
fiscale noire.
200 millions d'euros
d'impôts sont demandés
en plus à nos habitants.
Cela équivaut
à doubler l'impôt
sur le revenu.
Nous savons
qu'augmenter les impôts
sur une économie malade
n'est pas utile.
La solution, on la connaît tous.
C'est d'offrir
à la Nouvelle-Calédonie
un nouveau statut,
en réformant la Constitution
de manière à offrir
à notre pays
des perspectives durables.
Ma question est simple.
Est-ce que vous vous engagez
à réformer
la Constitution
le plus vite possible
pour aboutir
à un nouveau statut
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Nicolas Metzdorf,
comme vous l'avez rappelé,
le processus politique prévu
par les accords
de Nouméa est allé
à son terme.
Les calédoniens ont choisi
de demeurer français.
Notre devoir collectif
est désormais
de dessiner l'avenir
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie
au plan économique, par exemple.
Vous l'avez dit,
l'enjeu du nickel
est fondamental.
Mais aussi au plan institutionnel.
Pour cela, il fallait
créer les conditions
d'un dialogue serein
et constructif
avec les indépendantistes
et les non-indépendantistes.
C'est ce que nous avons fait
ces derniers mois
avec le président
de la République
le gouvernement.
Lors de sa visite
en Nouvelle-Calédonie
en juillet dernier,
le président
de la République a invité
les acteurs politiques
à travailler à la recherche
de consensus
sur tous les sujets,
en empruntant
deux chemins:
celui du pardon
et celui de l'avenir.
C'est le sens de la semaine
de discussion
qui s'est tenue début
septembre à Paris,
à mon invitation.
J'ai réuni tous
les acteurs à Matignon.
Gérald Darmanin a obtenu
de nombreux échanges
avec les délégations.
A l'issue de ces travaux,
le président
a réuni toutes les parties
pour dresser
des perspectives,
avec pour objectif
la conclusion
d'un accord d'ici la fin
de l'année.
Un projet d'accord
a été transmis
la semaine dernière
par le ministre
de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer,
Gérald Darmanin.
Je sais
que des discussions
sont en cours sur le thème
de la citoyenneté calédonienne.
Je vous confirme
que le moment venu,
le gouvernement
présentera un projet
de révision constitutionnelle.
Celui-ci devra
permettre le dégel
du corps électoral,
qui est une exigence démocratique.
Les calédoniens
devront approuver
le projet d'accord
comme ils l'ont
fait pour les accords
de Nouméa en 1998.
Une fois en vigueur,
des élections provinciales
pourront se tenir.
Je connais votre mobilisation
pour porter
la voix et les aspirations
des Calédoniens.
Notre objectif est de donner
des perspectives
à tous les Calédoniens,
notamment
les plus jeunes.
Notre objectif
est de leur permettre
de se projeter
et de construire
leur avenir
en Nouvelle-Calédonie
et dans la République.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Adrien Quatennens.
- Adrien Quatennens: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à Roland Lescure.
Monsieur le ministre,
anciennement
une autre usine,
il y a une entreprise implantée
en France qui produit
des roues
ou des galets utilisés
pour la maintenance
des écluses et c'est la seule.
Cette entreprise a vu
ses effectifs passer
à 350 salariés.
Depuis la reprise,
les pertes s'enchaînent.
16 millions d'euros
rien qu'en 2022.
En cause: le manque
d'investissement
du repreneur, contrairement
à ses engagements,
et l'abandon
de l'outil industriel.
Dès la reprise,
le repreneur aurait filmé
les processus
de production et copié
les brevets
pour les transférer
vers les sites
de production chinois.
L'actionnaire majoritaire
a ensuite annoncé
ce -- se retirer du capital
de l'entreprise.
C'est une prédation
industrielle
bien connue.
Les salariés,
par la voix de la CGT,
portent un projet
chiffré pour l'avenir
de Valdunes.
Ce projet réunit
l'ensemble des acteurs
du ferroviaire,
de la SNCF à Alstom,
en passant par les collectivités.
Monsieur le ministre,
vous représenterez l'Etat
dans ce projet.
On ne peut pas parler
de planification écologique
ni de souveraineté industrielle
et laisser couler Valdunes.
Quels engagements
comptez-vous prendre
pour accompagner
efficacement le projet
de la CGT pour Valdunes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Roland Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
la souveraineté industrielle
ne se décrète pas.
Ce n'est pas un slogan.
La politique industrielle
de la France
que nous menons
a créé de l'emploi
et a créé des entreprises,
des usines.
Vous avez voté
systématiquement contre.
La stratégie industrielle,
c'est aussi
une stratégie qui,
dossier après dossier,
travaillt avec l'ensemble
des acteurs.
Les organisations
syndicales
que je rencontre
depuis le début
sur ce dossier également.
Les actionnaires
que vous détestez tant,
les directions d'entreprise,
les élus locaux...
Depuis que l'actionnaire
a annoncé
se désengager,
c'était en mai dernier,
nous avons rencontré
les salariés
sur le terrain un mois après.
Nous avons négocié
avec l'actionnaire
des primes, des salaires
et des commandes
qui ont permis de gagner du temps.
Aujourd'hui,
nous avons le temps
de trouver des repreneurs.
Ces repreneurs doivent
être crédibles.
Ils doivent être capables
de s'engager
dans l'avenir de l'entreprise.
Je préférerais
un repreneur crédible
sur les dossiers,
mais je n'en
ai pas encore.
En revanche,
nous avons des marques d'intérêt
réelles pour tous
les sites des usines.
Suite à des discussions
que j'ai eues
avec des élus
représentés sur ce banc,
comme Fabien Roussel,
nous travaillons
avec les parties
prenantes, dont Alstom
et SNCF, qui seront au minimum
des acheteurs importants
qui doivent s'engager.
A la demande
de Sophie Binet
et de la CGT, j'ai organisé
une table ronde
qui réunira Xavier Bertrand,
les représentants
des entreprises et de la CGT,
pour voir comment Alstom
et la SNCF peuvent nous aider.
Nous travaillons.
Nous allons continuer à le faire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Adrien Quatennens:
Monsieur le ministre,
récemment,
vous avez dit au syndicat
qu'on ne gagne pas tous
les combats.
J'ai envie de vous dire
qu'il faut
encore les mener.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Louis Bricout.
- Jean-Louis Bricout: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre en charge
des Comptes publics.
Vous ne savez plus où taper
en matière d'austérité budgétaire.
Vous vous attaquez
maintenant aux centres
des métiers qui gèrent
les centres
de formation des apprentis.
Vous nous aviez proposé
des mesures.
D'abord, une ponction
de 29 millions
sur les cotisations des artisans.
Pour faire face
à cette austérité budgétaire,
la direction nationale
des chambres
des métiers
menace de fermer
les plus petits
centres de formation,
dont celui qui est dans ma
circonscription.
Allez-vous prendre des mesures?
Allez-vous raisonner
la gouvernance
des chambres de métiers
pour leur dire
qu'il ne faut pas jouer
avec la ruralité?
Il ne faut pas toucher
aux outils
de formation de proximité.
Ils sont indispensables
à nos artisans
en mal de recrutement.
Fermer un centre
d'apprentis,
c'est mettre plus de 250
jeunes désoeuvrés
à la rue.
Chez nous, nos jeunes
choisissent souvent
leur avenir
au regard de l'offre
de proximité des formations.
Vous devez comprendre
cette réalité rurale.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Carole Grandjean.
- Carole Grandjean: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Bricout, comme vous,
nous pensons
que l'apprentissage
est une voie favorable aux jeunes.
Le gouvernement
a réussi à installer
une politique
publique d'envergure
dans ce domaine,
en ayant fait un choix fort,
celui de promouvoir
l'apprentissage
et d'y mettre
des dispositions juridiques
et des moyens,
permettant son essor
comme jamais.
Depuis 2018,
nous sommes passés de 1000
à 3500 centres de formation
pour apprentissage.
Nous avons trois fois
plus d'apprentis
qu'il y a cinq ans.
Aujourd'hui,
nous avons plus de 900.000
apprentis nouveaux
qui sont entrés
en centre
de formation
et nous avons l'objectif
d'aller
vers un million d'apprentis.
Cet objectif est au fond
assez simple.
C'est d'accompagner
un modèle de financement
qui accompagne
les dépenses engagées
tout en prévenant le risque
de marges excessives opérées
par certains organismes
de formation.
Nous l'avons constaté,
il y a des écarts
encore importants
entre les niveaux
de prise en charge
et les coût réels engagés
par les organismes de formation.
Il s'agit d'engager
une démarche
de juste prix,
en responsabilité
avec nos finances publiques.
Pour autant,
le gouvernement
n'est pas aveugle
aux difficultés
de certains petits CFA.
Nous avons, dans la loi
de 2018, octroyé
des moyens aux régions.
138 millions d'euros
servent à majorer
les niveaux
de prise en charge
pour maintenir
une offre de formation
de proximité dans les territoires.
180 millions d'euros
pour soutenir
les investissements ont été
mis en place aussi.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
-
Jean-Louis Bricout:
Vous ne répondez pas
complètement
à ma question
ni aux besoins de proximité
des formations
pour la jeunesse
sur nos territoires ruraux.
Ce sont des crédits
qu'il faut sauvegarder.
D'autres pistes sont possibles
en matière d'économies
pour renforcer
les crédits versés --
vers ces centres
de proximité, d'une part
de mieux répartir
les budgets
sur les territoires
en tenant compte
plus franchement
de leurs besoins
et en tenant compte
des spécificités
et des formations dispensées.
D'autre part, il faudrait
mutualiser certaines dépenses
communes aux chambres consulaires.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Stéphanie Kochert.
- Stéphanie Kochert: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre chargée
des personnes handicapées.
Madame la ministre,
pilier des accords
du Ségur de la santé de 2020,
la prime Ségur
a permis une meilleure
reconnaissance
du travail fourni
par une revalorisation
des salaires à hauteur
de 183 euros nets
par mois.
Cette revalorisation devait
concerner uniquement
les personnels exerçant
en milieu hospitalier.
Elle a finalement été
étendue aux soignants
des secteurs sociaux
et médico-sociaux.
Les services généraux
des hôpitaux publics,
les agents d'entretien
ou de maintenance
ont aussi bénéficié
d'une augmentation
de leur salaire.
Le soutien
du gouvernement
ne s'arrête pas là.
Les personnels des EHPAD ont aussi
bénéficié d'augmentations
de salaires.
Enfin, début septembre,
la Première ministre annonçait
une revalidation
des primes de nuit,
des jours fériés et d'astreinte.
C'était pour les personnels
des hôpitaux.
Ce sont des mesures
fortes et bienvenues
pour ce secteur.
Toutefois,
j'aimerais attirer
votre attention
sur le déséquilibre
que ces revalorisations
créent
avec d'autres établissements
médico-sociaux
qui n'en bénéficient pas.
C'est le cas notamment
des établissements
du secteur du handicap,
où la différence
de salaire avec les personnels
des EHPAD peut atteindre jusqu'à
300 euros par mois.
Cela entraîne une fuite
de certains professionnels
vers d'autres secteurs
plus rémunérateurs.
Les établissements accueillant
des personnes atteintes
d'un handicap connaissent
des situations similaires
aux EHPAD.
Les conditions de travail
sont difficiles.
Il faut travailler tôt
le matin et tard
le soir, de nuit,
les week-ends et jours fériés.
Les grilles salariales
restent inchangées.
Madame la ministre,
nous devons soutenir
ce secteur et ne pas créer
une situation
de concurrence
entre des métiers
qui ont une même vocation:
accompagner dignement
des personnes en situation
de vulnérabilité.
Quelles mesures
le gouvernement envisage
en faveur de ces métiers
essentiels?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Fadila Khattabi.
- Fadila Khattabi: Merci.
Madame la députée,
je vous remercie
pour cette question
cruciale qui porte
sur l'attractivité
des métiers
et qui constitue
l'une des priorités
pour le gouvernement.
Vous évoquez à juste
titre la question
des rémunérations
et de leur alignement
dans les différents secteurs,
en particulier
pour les nouvelles
mesures
que vous avez évoquées,
concernant
le travail de nuit,
les jours fériés
et les astreintes.
Rappelons que ces mesures
sont déjà étendues
à tous les établissements
publics accueillant
des personnes
en situation de handicap.
Concernant les établissements
privés non-lucratifs,
vous savez peut-être
que des négociations
sont en cours
entre les partenaires sociaux
pour parvenir à une convention
collective nationale unique.
Cette convention
devra concerner
toute la branche associative
du secteur sanitaire,
social et médico-social.
Nous souhaitons,
avec la ministre
des Solidarités,
que cette convention revalorise
les salaires
les plus bas, améliore
la mobilité des professionnels
et s'assure
que tous soient
bien couverts
par une convention protectrice.
Je suis certaine
que dans le cadre
de ces discussions,
la question
des conditions de travail
et des horaires
est abordée.
Sur ces sujets,
le gouvernement prendra
toute sa part de responsabilité.
Nous l'avons toujours fait.
Je rappelle que le 1er
juillet 2022,
nous avons consacré
un milliard d'euros
à la revalorisation
des salaires
des professionnels concernés.
Nous connaissons
tout le travail
qui est effectué au quotidien
pour accompagner
les personnes
en situation de handicap
ou les personnes âgées.
Permettez-moi à travers
cette intervention
de leur rendre hommage.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Patrick Hetzel.
- Patrick Hetzel: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
en charge de l'Enseignement
supérieur
de la recherche.
Récemment,
nous nous sommes tous réjouis
à l'annonce des lauréats
du prix Nobel
de physique.
Deux chercheurs français
ont été primés.
Je tiens à les en féliciter.
Toutefois,
il y a une ombre au tableau.
Lorsque vous regardez
les institutions
où sont en poste
nos deux physiciens,
le constat est sévère.
Ils exercent
dans des universités étrangères
et pas dans des institutions
françaises.
La recherche est internationale.
Mais la conséquence directe,
c'est qu'une grande partie
de la renommée
de ces prix Nobel retombe
sur des institutions
étrangères
et pas sur des institutions
françaises.
Est-ce que vous acceptez
que le combat
pour le retour de nos meilleurs
chercheurs français,
dont les prix Nobel,
actuellement
en poste à l'étranger,
soient érigés
en grande cause nationale?
Il en va du futur
de la performance
de notre recherche
et de notre innovation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Sylvie Retailleau.
- Sylvie Retailleau: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Patrick Hetzel,
je voudrais d'abord
vous remercier
pour votre question
qui me permet
de rappeler non
seulement l'excellence
de notre recherche,
mais aussi
de nos formations.
Nous avons fait
beaucoup pour soutenir
nos chercheurs.
A travers eux,
cela nous permet de maintenir
la France au rang de grande
nation scientifique
et d'être le pays
le plus attractif
en Europe
pour les investissements
en recherche
et développement,
notamment grâce au crédit
impôt-recherche.
Je vais répondre
sur les prix Nobel.
Je voudrais dire
que ces deux prix Nobel français,
dont l'un a fait
toute sa carrière
en France, il est parti
à l'étranger
à sa retraite.
Pour l'autre,
elle est partie
pour des projets personnels.
Tous deux ont eu
cette récompense
pour des réalisations
qu'ils ont faites
en France.
Comme le prix Nobel français
de l'année dernière,
qui a fait
toute sa carrière en France
et qui est toujours
en France aujourd'hui,
dans nos laboratoires.
Je voudrais aussi
parler de la loi
de programmation
pour la recherche,
qui apporte
une question concrète
à la question
de la rémunération
de nos chercheurs.
Le travail que l'on fait
actuellement
pour la simplification
au quotidien
de la vie de nos chercheurs
est utile.
C'est une augmentation
de 16%
de la rémunération
de nos doctorants.
C'est une augmentation
de 20 à 30%
de la rémunération
de nos jeunes chercheurs,
ce sont des chaires
de professeurs juniors
qui connaissent
un véritable succès.
Un tiers des lauréats
reviennent
de l'étranger.
Ce sont aussi
les chaires d'excellence
en santé, avec un financement
de France 2030,
qui permettent d'attirer
les meilleurs.
C'est une cause
importante pour nous.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le député?
- Patrick Hetzel: Merci.
J'entends bien.
Ce qu'il faut
vraiment noter,
c'est qu'il y a 10
ans,
nous étions encore en cinquième
place
en terme de participation
aux publications mondiales.
Aujourd'hui,
nous sommes passés en 10e place.
L'attractivité est un problème.
Les mesures
que vous avez prises
sont insuffisantes.
J'insiste
sur le fait que l'un
des deux prix Nobel
de physique a déclaré
qu'il était allé
à l'étranger
parce que la France
n'avait pas assur -- assuré
les conditions
lui permettant de poursuivre
son activité en France.
C'est un problème
récurrent
que nous avons aujourd'hui.
Il faut aller plus loin.
Il en va du rayonnement
de notre activité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Dominique Potier.
- Dominique Potier: Merci.
Le 7 octobre,
nous avons condamné
le terrorisme du Hamas en Israël.
10 jours après,
nous alertons
sur la situation dramatique
du peuple palestinien.
A Gaza,
des civils meurent
sous les bombardements.
Les enfants
sont les premières victimes
des pénuries,
celle des hôpitaux,
des médicaments,
de l'eau et de l'énergie.
Il reste quatre à cinq jours
de nourriture
dans le territoire de Gaza.
Les Palestiniens
ne peuvent payer
le prix de la barbarie du Hamas.
Le groupe socialiste est clair.
Il affirme sa même
solidarité
avec le droit
du peuple israélien
et le droit du peuple palestinien.
Notre ligne
est claire,
c'est celle du droit
humanitaire
et international.
Chaque jour,
chaque vie compte,
et un enfant a la même
valeur d'un côté
ou de l'autre.
Nous avons trois questions
à vous poser.
Par les airs, par la mer
ou le sol égyptien,
où en est la diplomatie
française
pour faire avancer
les couloirs humanitaires?
Quels sont les amendements
que porte
la France pour faire
triompher une résolution
au Conseil de sécurité,
celles portées notamment
par la puissance brésilienne?
Quelle est la ligne
diplomatique
de la France?
Enfin, dans cette région
qui a porté
tant de sang
et d'espérance,
où en est la diplomatie
française
et européenne?
Il faut créer
un espace de paix
et un chemin de paix.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Chrysoula Zacharopoulou:
Monsieur
le député Dominique Potier,
le président
de la République
et la Première ministre
ont multiplié, depuis le début
de l'attaque terroriste,
des actions pour éviter
l'embrasement régional.
Notre soutien à Israël ne souffre
d'aucune ambiguïté.
Visé par des actes
terroristes, Israël
a subi une offensive
sans précédent
de son histoire.
La France se tient
aux côtés d'Israël.
Rien ne justifie
le terrorisme,
comme l'a dit la ministre.
Israël a le droit de se défendre.
La ministre,
lors de son déplacement,
a rappelé
qu'il fallait le faire
dans le respect
du droit international.
La France agit dans ce sens.
Catherine Colonna
a annoncé au Caire
une aide de 10
millions d'euros,
aux agences
des Nations Unies
et aux ONG humanitaires
qui bénéficient
à la population de Gaza.
Il faut que les civils
qui souhaitent sortir
de Gaza puissent le faire.
Le Hamas doit cesser
de les en empêcher.
Soyez assuré, monsieur,
que les efforts
de la France
vont continuer pour éviter
toute escalade régionale.
C'est aussi une priorité
du déplacement
de la ministre
Catherine Colonna
au Proche-Orient.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Barthès.
- Christophe Barthès: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur Marc Fesneau.
Alors que les vendanges
touchent
à leur fin, le constat est clair.
La viticulture
française
est en train de mourir.
Baisse de la consommation de vin,
aléas climatiques,
manque de réserve
d'eau et dénigrement
de nos viticulteurs,
comme le font certains députés
présents ici.
Ce secteur représente près
de 500.000 emplois
sur le territoire national.
Il incarne le vivre
à la française.
La catastrophe est aussi humaine.
Je vous ai déjà
alerté à travers
des courriers.
Peu de mesures ont été prises.
Le 26 juillet 2022,
je disais à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire
que la cocotte-minute
était pleine
et qu'elle allait
vous péter à la figure.
Chez moi, dans l'Aude,
la viticulture
fait partie du tourisme
et est importante
pour l'économie.
Les viticulteurs
ne se laisseront
pas faire.
De nombreuses actions
vont avoir lieu.
Il y a quelques jours,
le comité d'action viticole
a tenté de mettre
le feu à un négoce.
Un drame a été évité de justesse.
Nous devons éviter
que le ras-le-bol
de la profession
ne dégénère en violence.
Monsieur le ministre,
que comptez-vous faire
pour sauver rapidement
la viticulture française?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Marc Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Barthès, merci
de votre question.
Aucune violence n'est acceptable.
Je ne voudrais pas accréditer
ici
la thèse
qui pourrait dire
qu'elle est acceptable.
Nous devons faire
en sorte de trouver
les voies de l'apaisement.
Vous nous demandez
ce que l'on fait
sur la viticulture.
Nous avons agi
continuellement
et le gouvernement
a été au rendez-vous
des crises conjoncturelles
devenues structurelles.
Il y a eu un milliard sur le gel.
Sur l'Aude,
nous avons agi cette année
pour faire face à l'épisode
de la sécheresse
cette année.
Nous avons besoin
d'accompagner
les gens.
Il y a eu l'exonération
des charges.
Il y a près de 30
millions d'euros
qui seront là pour aider.
On va documenter
les pertes liées
à la sécheresse cette année.
On les aura au moment
des déclarations
de récolte.
On regardera
ce qui est pris en charge
par les assurances.
Il faut se projeter
au-delà de l'année 2023
et 2024 également.
Il faut qu'il y ait
encore une viticulture.
Il y a les sujets
d'accès à l'eau,
de résilience,
le problème des cépages,
pour que les viticulteurs
aient
des projets d'avenir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur le député?
- Christophe Barthès:
Le problème
de l'eau doit
être réglé rapidement.
Le 4 mars,
un viticulteur avait perdu
la vie lors de manifestations.
Nous devons tout faire
pour éviter
ce genre de drames.
Il faut sauver
la viticulture française.
Mais rapidement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La séance des questions
au gouvernement
est terminée.
Nous reprendrons
tout à l'heure
sur le vote sur le projet
de loi visant
à sécuriser l'espace numérique.